in a year we've been saved by science
many behind the breakthroughs have been
women catherine janssen one of the
leading researchers at pfizer
kismikia corbett co-developer of the
moderna jab
and professor sarah gilbert creator of
the oxford vaccine
she's now been recognized with the
albert medal an honor reserved for minds
like mary curie and stephen hawking
whilst women like her have been at the
forefront of saving lives
professor gilbert says there is a
distinct lack of women
reaching the top what i think might be
happening is that women are sometimes a
bit reluctant to step forward
and take on the leadership roles and so
if that's true what we need to do
is to give them more confidence in their
ability to do that and that's looking at
things like mentoring
and training and helping them understand
how to
to progress in the career training like
these science and digital technology
students are benefiting from
this generation of innovators are
empowered by their predecessors
i think with the women at the forefront
the women who are getting the vaccines
out to people the women who have
been a key part of the research it's
definitely an inspiring thing and it's
definitely something that is going to
cause many many young girls to look at
them and see oh
i could do that that's somebody that
looks like me that's somebody
that i could be in the future the fact
that we've all come together
now and like women have come and rose to
the challenge and sort of came up with
these solutions without
uh despite the bias and despite the
adversities they may have faced
i feel like that in itself will live on
beyond
the pandemic their classrooms are filled
with leaders too
shafina has founded a groundbreaking
engineering program using lego
i do think it starts young i think it
starts very early in the home even
getting them to play and explore with
with gadgets women other people that
come up with those quick ideas or quick
fixes when something's gone wrong in the
morning
so i think we need to capitalize on that
professor angela mclean is another
guiding light on the national stage as
the ministry of defense's first
female chief scientific advisor she
hopes there are some positives to come
from the past year
it would be such a great spin-off of
this difficult year
if more women were to consider
uh doing a stem subject uh for for their
university education
uh because they saw that there were all
sorts of interesting jobs for women
scientists
this snapshot of pioneering minds on the
front line of science
reaffirms the world is in good hands
their gender
is just an added bonus ashley haranag
sky news